no time to die is all about endings
bringing daniel craig's 15-year run as
james bond to a close it's a sprawling
epic that's both action-packed and
tragic it also does something no bond
movie before has ever done this is the
ending of no time to die explained
every bond movie has an extravagant
villain with an even more elaborate plan
for world domination no time to die has
new threat to lucifer saffin a
megalomaniac with a grudge and a
peculiar worldview who thinks of himself
as a kindred spirit to bond license to
kill
i could be speaking to my own reflection
earlier in the film bond traces a
russian scientist to a specter meeting
in cuba there he discovers that blofeld
is still running the shady organization
from behind bars through the use of his
bionic eye blowfeld attempts to use a
bioweapon that's been acquired from the
scientist orbiter a genetically targeted
virus made of nanobots called project
heracles to kill bond but orbachev at
the behest of his true boss saffin
reverses the programming of the weapon
to kill every member of spectre in
attendance instead safin saves bond's
life as he once did for madeleine swann
bond's estranged lover when madeline was
a young girl saffin sought revenge
against her father mr white for killing
his family he killed madeleine's mother
but chose to spare her life a mercy he
uses for leverage later in the film to
make her a pawn in his successful plot
to kill blofeld and end spectre forever
bond has been suspicious of madeleine
since the film's opening scene when she
led him into a trap at the grave of west
berlin
but bond soon realizes the trap was
entirely blowfield's plan to drive them
apart seeing that she has been used by
outside forces bond runs to norway to
find madeleine and finds a big surprise
awaiting him
five years passed and no time to die
from the film's harrowing opening
breakup between bund and madeline to the
main thrusts of the story but when bond
reunites with madeleine and apologizes
for the time they've lost while apart he
discovers she has a daughter mathilde
though madeline insists he is not the
father it is very clear she is not
telling the truth after he meets his
daughter madeline phils bond in on her
past with saffin how he saved her life
and has a strange obsession with her and
how his parents used to be the chief
poison makers for spectre bond with help
from q is able to track safin to his
base on an island in murky international
waters between russia and japan where he
is manufacturing project heracles on a
grand enough scale to deploy it globally
but before bond could embark on his
mission to kill safin and stop project
heracles from spreading further saffin
and his men come and kidnap madeleine
and their daughter bond must infiltrate
safin's island with the help of the new
double 07 nomi while trying to avoid
sparking an international incident and
causing even more trouble for mi6 the
agency that helps develop this deadly
weapon in the first place
bond and nomi storm saffin's base
neutralizing orbitshev and mowing their
way through saffin's henchmen bond is
able to reunite with the kidnapped pair
and also he now knows for certain that
one is indeed his daughter nomi gets him
off the island to safety so he can get
to the center of the base and disable
the blast door shielding that protects
saffin's operation from outside harm em
is prepared to authorize a surgical
strike of missiles to destroy saffin's
island and prevent project heracles from
being deployed but it can't be done
until bond destroys the defense system
it's a suitably harrowing nail-biting
sequence complete with a ticking clock
of inbound missiles but in his final
altercation with saffin bond is exposed
to a version of the bioweapon that's
genetically locked to madeleine's dna in
killing saffin bond dooms himself
because if he makes it off this island
and comes into contact with madeline or
his daughter he will infect and kill
them both resigned to his fate bond
lowers the island's defenses and saves
his final goodbyes overcomes to the love
of his life and the daughter he never
got to know
james bond is dead long live james bond
back at mi6 headquarters m eulogizes
bond by sharing a drink with nomi q tana
and money penny over the course of the
last few films each of these former
colleagues has developed their own
meaningful rapport with bond and the
knowledge that he died saving the world
cut off from a daughter he didn't even
know he had weighs heavily on the entire
group
elsewhere madeline drives off into the
sunset with daughter in tow still
struggling with loss but looking at her
daughter who she remarks as james's eyes
she promises matild to tell her a story
a story about a man named bond james
bond
so what happens now do i look like i
give it james bond has never died in a
movie before despite 24 previous films
full of near-death experiences because
of the franchise's murky continuity none
of the other bonds final outings were
creatively conceived that way up until
casino royale intentionally rebooted the
series the first 20 movies essentially
followed the same james bond but with no
time to die being imagined from the
outset as craig's final outing the
filmmakers felt free to tell a story
with far more finality than any bond
movie before it but just because this
bond is dead it doesn't mean james bond
himself is being retired the last
message in the credits echo is what so
many other bond movies before it have
promised james bond will return not
double 007 james bond that basically
proves we'll be getting another reboot
of the character in the next bond movie
leading up to no time to die new entries
in the bond franchise have elicited
think pieces about whether or not bond
can still work on screen in a changing
world
man talk
no time to die proof you don't have to
drastically change bond as a person
instead you need to change the world
around him and create drama out of that
juxtaposition whether the next take on
bond is a drastic departure or a careful
refinement of what has come before the
bold conclusion for no time to die has
set the stage for bond to endure here's
to the next 25 movies
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
bond james barnes are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you